Huntsville Texas more prisoners have
been executed in this penitentiary than
any other jail in the United States from
murderers to petty criminals
thousands more languish behind bars for
decades they're gonna let you out the
back gate over here you go across the
street and walk down to the left
these men are about to be released if
your family is here to pick you up
they'll be right across the street but
the chances are they'll be back I've
been a concentrate all my life and I
never had no kids so I don't have a
family I got cousin somewheres in
Louisiana but I really don't know this
is my family this is all I know
reoffending is one of the greatest
challenges facing justice systems
worldwide
but could it be that prisons themselves
are at the heart of this global problem
families of the inmates have an anxious
wait across the road from the
penitentiary but for the prisoners their
first taste of freedom can be
overwhelming they're tired they probably
haven't had a good night's sleep in two
or three nights they haven't eaten right
they're off their medication a former
prisoner himself bill Kleiber knows the
difficulties these men will face over
the next 24 hours
the most difficult thing that they're
going to have to overcome is moving from
being a child to an adult see inside
there they treat us like children
they've been making about five decisions
a day now they're making five decisions
a minute
they have little to help them start a
new life they're given $50 on release a
shirt trousers and a pair of shoes those
lucky enough to have the support of
families head for home
the others have to fend for themselves
Olly Matthews has been in and out of
prison since he was 16 well we've gotten
a nice hot barbecue sandwich and a fresh
pack of Marlboro cigarettes cause almost
$5 the last time I was here to love the
50 sitting at a file hour these released
prisoners are all on parole are you
gonna wait for the Yaquis then work out
those with no fixed address or family
are sent to halfway houses all over
Texas I got a busted they gave me a
voucher to Houston today I don't know
where I'm gonna go after that but I'm
heading to Houston today so all he's
struggled with a heroin addiction since
he was 13 but if he falls back into old
habits or breaches his parole he'll be
straight back in the penitentiary
all right go the odds are stacked
against these men like in many countries
more than half of X prisoners are back
behind bars before long
but there's one country that's taking a
very different approach this is Norway's
bastoy prison nestled in the oslofjord a
short boat ride from the nearest town
this island is home to 115 inmates all
convicted of serious crimes from drug
trafficking to murder but this is no
Alcatraz our main task is to produce a
good neighbor
all the guys staying here for shorter or
longer time have that in common
that they're going to be released at
some point to a normal society out there
and to be someone's neighbor down and go
whoa whoa whoa
bastoy is a flagship example of Norway's
liberal approach to justice all of the
inmates have been transferred from
locked prisons and will spend up to
three years here in preparation for
release under the watchful eye of warden
tom Aberhart and 35 other prison
officers normal prisons you're actually
taking care of all the time or less
you're told when to eat you're told what
to do we are completely dependent upon
the inmates on this place to actually
make this more society go around if
you're a person that is actually is
going to survive in normal society
you'll have to learn how to take
responsibility
from the ferry service to the farm
carpentry to butchery the island is
mostly self-sufficient and run by the
prisoners in their work they have access
to potentially lethal tools a fact that
doesn't seem to concern the employed
head chef I've been here for almost 15
years I think I've never been afraid not
that was their normal people almost one
of the islands longest-serving prisoners
is hands Petter Hansen he's on an
18-year stretch the last two of which
have been spent here it's our living
room but it's also our practice room so
uh this is all we're all the funnies so
um we practice here for three four five
nights a week
he leads the prison's blues band
when you're in maximum-security prison
you you get your guard up you close away
a lot of things you have to be very
primitive in the the way you think
like a caveman but here I can try to be
more normal again Norway's liberal
attitude to justice has been mocked as
an oddball social experiment but it is
getting results in the United States
reoffending rates are 77% in Norway it's
20% an international benchmark helped by
prisons like bastoy which has a
reoffending rate of just 16% it takes
more than statistics to shift decades of
global consensus on punishment
especially in countries where talking
tough on crime wins votes time is
running out for the merchants of crime
and corruption in American society they
can go to jail and they can stay in jail
and they can rot in jail three strikes
and you are out the United States is
feeling the full impact of decades of
hardline policies although the country
has only 5% of the world's population it
has 25% of the world's prison population
in a career spanning 30 years Texan
judge Bobby Frances has convicted his
fair share of criminals I prosecuted
someone who received the death penalty
I've signed the death warrant on six or
seven people as a judge I'm not soft on
crime in the 90s he was gaining a
reputation for being a no-nonsense judge
but he soon realized that he wasn't
getting the results he wanted when you
realize all you're doing is sending two
people to prison and you send them over
and over when I start recognizing people
the second third or fourth time they
come through you begin to thank wait a
second this isn't working this is a
bunch of BS all we do is double the cost
crime rates continue to go up
judge Frances now runs a very different
type of courtroom it's turning back a
centuries-old hardline approach to
punishment in a bid to bring down the
cost of criminal justice by doing it
this court deals with serial offenders
who have already been convicted but
instead of serving another long prison
stretch they've spent up to nine months
in a prison reform facility before being
released into a rehabilitation program
each week they face the unique justice
of Judge Francis does anybody know Alex
Garcia I spoke with him earlier he said
he was gonna show up to court okay I
mean cuz he's missing stuff he knows
he's going to jail but if he doesn't
show up he'll make it worse I get asked
all the time whether or not I'm soft on
crime and I've given the same answer
every time anybody that comes and sits
in my courtroom and watches me interact
with the folks and thinks I'm soft on
crime has got to be a low functioning
idiot if you show up and you're dirty
you better have told me before you ever
went and peed in that cup there are
consequences for repeated parole
breaches or failing a drug or alcohol
test and if you don't do either of those
and you don't continue to show up like
mr. Garcia you end up in prison and so
you get you got to make a decision I go
to a few years in prison [ __ ] I miss
those group showers I got to get back to
prison man that's just nothing better
than somebody scratching your back if I
can get them to stay sober get a job be
responsible maybe they don't repeat the
criminal activity and they change their
behavior I've been spending a lot of
time with my daughter lately I got to go
a little go to a little graduation too
first and I've never done that before
and it just it it kind of hit my heart
because just seeing her get her little
certificate and everything and looking
and looking at her look for us in the in
the crowd and this is amazing it just it
really I think I think God for where I'm
at right now
and I'm not still in my addiction good
deal good man when Judge Francis started
his re-entry court in 2001 there were
just a few in Texas now there are nearly
250 in that time the state incarceration
rate has fallen by 16 percent our
incarceration rates have dropped there's
no question about that have they dropped
where we wanted to be no of course not
are we doing enough and re-entry and
prison reform and criminal justice
reform no but we're on the right path
for hours after being released from
prison
Ollie Matthews has arrived in Houston
but he's already lost his money and some
important documents what's that in your
pocket is that your bus Jake no no only
I don't have it was two years
I don't even held him worldwide there
are ten million prisoners like Ollie
most of them have inadequate preparation
or support when they're released he just
got out of Huntsville today he doesn't I
don't have his parole papers thank you
thank you for your help
hey wanna go check the bus and see if it
ain't on the bus cuz I they don't know
okay they're not gonna
Olle heads across town to the halfway
house where he'll have a bed for the
next few days
no wonder where no science no nothing
this is what I got
didn't this worked my my life of 59
years old this is what I own in life
right here in this red sack and what I
got on my back I don't know what I want
to do I'm free dough free if I ain't
nothing else I'm free
the challenge for justice systems in any
country is keeping offenders out of
prison for good you could check five
years by a muscle now I will never be
back to prison
never until rehabilitation is put at the
heart of justice systems approach to
punishment they'll continue to fail
offenders fail victims and fail
societies
you're there to go you'll have a good
deal all right nice meeting y'all have a
nice time
you